la branche fois que j'ai pensé à
applause et cette vidéo c'était il ya un
an je médite tous les jours depuis un an
genre chaque jour j'ai pas raté un seul
jour c'est pas une vidéo sur méditation
c'est une vidéo sur l'habitude genre
comment on crée une habitude parce
qu'avant c'était hyper compliqué pour
moi je me crée de nouvelles résolutions
à chaque fois et à chaque fois vraiment
j'y arrivais pas je tenais un mois même
pas bref c'était compliqué et ça depuis
très longtemps depuis que je suis ado je
pense j'ai lu masse de libre j'ai
regardé masse de conférence je me suis
beaucoup observé et caetera et j'ai
réussi je me suis créé une habitude
alors mes amis dans cette vidéo je vais
tout faire pour vous transmettre ce truc
que j'ai appris et vous donner mes
meilleurs conseils
c'est un peu comme une recette pour moi
il ya cinq ingrédients on va le voir un
parra a oui et ça va être une vidéo fait
scam et c'est en vrai je voulais faire
un truc un peu plus chialer un peu plus
cool et tout mais les gars vraiment
enfin je vous montrais soulageant
déménagement etc
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il ya moins de
vidéos sur la chaîne donc mais par
contre c'est important que je la sorte
avant noël et tout et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi et je veux dire
aussi que ça me fait plaisir de vous
voir ça fait très longtemps qu'on a peut
être fait escale comme ça mais bon on
passe aux premières invasions
[Musique]
une bonne raison de le faire ça paraît
évident mais il faut vraiment une bonne
raison de le faire un truc qui vous
motive vraiment de l'intérieur moi par
exemple avec la méditation j'avais fait
plusieurs stages assez intensif j'en
avais parlé sur cette chaîne et du coup
c'était évident qu'il fallait que
j'incorpore la méditation dans ma vie et
que ne pas le faire est un petit pas en
désaccord avec bam et nouvelles valeurs
et et la nouvelle personne que j'étais
quoi et ça peut être mille trucs ça peut
être perdre du poids dans ce cas-là
imaginait la nouvelle votre nouveau vous
où ça peut être l'un verse en gagner et
dans ce cas là pareil ça peut être
écrire une demi heure par jour pour
écrire un bouquin par exemple et dans ce
cas là imaginez votre produit fini la
fierté que vous aurez à genre faire lire
votre bouquin à vos proches
elle a envoyé en maison d'édition etc ça
peut être tout et n'importe quoi mais il
faut avoir une bonne raison de le faire
et si vous n'avez pas une bonne raison
et bien c'est que c'est peut-être pas
une bonne habitude achoppé c'est
peut-être le moment etc
ou alors peut-être que vous devriez en
trouver
[Musique]
se forcer à faire peu je sais très bien
comment ça se passe on a une nouvelle
résolution
on échoue nous dit ouais bah moi je vais
méditer une demi-heure par jour donc à
tous les jours c'est dur franchement une
demi heure par jour
ok ou alors moi je vais courir tous les
jours je vais aller courir au moins deux
kilomètres jeter n'importe quoi j'en
sais rien mais dans tous les cas même si
c'est l'intention est louable
le problème c'est que c'est rarement
table en fait sur le long terme vous
devez vous forcer à faire peut vous
devez vous forcer à faire un truc qui a
l'air ridicule je pense moi c'est comme
ça que j'ai réussi en tout cas par
exemple je fais seulement 10 minutes de
méditation par jour est là il y en a
devant leur écran qu'ils l'avaient ok
d'accord ok le mec break mais ils
étaient tous les jours en fait il fait
que dix minutes
peut-être mais maintenant 10 minutes
tous les jours à la fin de l'année bah
ça fait soixante heures quoi et je sais
très bien que si je m'étais dit vas-y je
médite une heure par jour
je n'aurais pas fait plus de 60 jours
dans l'année où je médite une heure par
jour je pense maintenant que j'ai dix
minutes
peut-être que l'année prochaine je passe
à 15 je sais pas pourquoi pas mais c'est
hyper important de se forcer à faire
peut par exemple si je me dis mon bas
l'année prochaine je vais vraiment cette
fois je vais boire plus d'eau je veux
pas me dire ok je bois un litre par jour
non trop complexe enfin je suis pas en
train de me rendre service là en fait
par contre par contre par contre si je
me dis je prends un verre comme ça voilà
le matin tous les matins je veux remplir
un verre comme ça et je bois beaucoup
plus facile à faire franchement 40
centilitres c'est toujours le même 0
quoi
[Musique]
l'attaché à une ancre alors qu'est ce
que j'appelle une encre j'appelle ça un
truc qui est déjà une habitude qui est
déjà très ancrée en fait dans votre
quotidien
par exemple pour moi la méditation gelé
rattaché au fait de se brosser les dents
le soir genre je peux pas aller au lit
me coucher 100 m brosser les dents genre
au niveau de la sensation et c'était
vraiment je ne peux pas jauger de me
réveiller me levais am brossé dans six
gelé si par malheur je n'ai oublié et
genre c'est très difficile d'oublier de
se brosser les dents le soir ok eh ben
je vais rattacher la méditation à ça et
maintenant entre le brossage de dents et
le coucher
prévoir la végétation et ben maintenant
ça me fait la même chose avec la
validation savent que quand je vais au
lit
si j'ai oublié de mérite et je fais pas
direct je le sais il ya un truc qui est
pas normal et un truc qui va pas donc
j'ai réussi à en faire une encre mais
c'est parce que je les rattacher à une
autre encre qui étaient déjà là par
exemple si je me mets à boire de l'eau
et ben je pense que le réveil c'est une
très bonne en croit avant le petit déj
ou avant de se laver le visage ou ce
genre de choses
voilà se laver le visage par exemple
super encre faut pas le mettre à ce
moment-là avoir point de départ fort
alors cet ingrédient là il est très en
lien avec le prochain c'est que c'est
bien de ne pas commencer ton truc
n'importe quand et c'est pour ça que les
gens souvent choisissent le 1er janvier
parce que c'est les résolutions et
caetera et c'est une date très forte
quoi le 1er janvier c'est une nouvelle
année nouveau mois entre guillemets ça
peut être d'autres dates comme par
exemple un anniversaire ton anniversaire
ou l'anniversaire d'autre chose ça peut
être un événement à un événement sportif
un truc une victoire ou une défaite un
truc fort quoi c'est hyper important de
je pense marquer le début de ton
habitude et tu vas comprendre pourquoi
et que la suite d'ailleurs le prochain
d'ingrédients c'est le dernier
ingrédient est juste avant de passer à
celui là vu que je sais qu'il est
probable que vous permet la vidéo et que
vous passez à autre chose et c'est pas
tous y met du coup si vous voulez mettre
un like ou
si les vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait et c'est ça me semble être un très
bon
[Musique]
la technique de la chaîne alors ça c'est
la clé vraiment de la création
d'habitude je vous explique l'idée c'est
donc à partir du point de départ qui est
fort vous allez créer une chaîne alors
vous pouvez la formaliser leur prendre
un calendrier et faire des croix sur
chaque jour ou bien genre ya par exemple
simone gates 2-1 jeudi son nom de tête
peut-être que je me trompe qui a fait un
calendrier luminaires où elle voit les
points etc
mais bref la technique de la chaîne
c'est une technique qui est finalement
assez connu et qui consiste à marquer
clairement chaque jour où vous le faites
ok c'est pour ça que c'est cool
d'anciennes habitudes qui est
quotidienne d'accord donc vous allez
créer une chaîne le but du jeu c'est de
ne pas briser cette chaîne est en fait
ce qui va se passer c'est que plus vous
allez avancer dans la création d'autres
habitudes et plus cette chaîne va être
grosses et plus en fait le coup du fait
de la brise et va être fort mais en fait
vous allez développer un attachement
n'ont pas forcément l'habitude mais à la
chaîne elle même et ça c'est hyper fort
comme mind tricks entre guillemets comme
manière de piéger un peu son cerveau
parce que du coup on se dit ok non en
fait j'ai enfin ça fait j'ai 23 comme ça
et tout ça me ferait chier d'avoir un un
trou je vais pas fait je m'arrangeais
pour ok pas trop en fait et donc je vais
continuer cette chaîne et je vais le
faire coûte que coûte et le fait de
commencer à un moment fort
ça vous pousse encore plus apte à faire
de trou parce que vous savez que vous
avez commencé cette chaîne à un moment
important et c est donc l a encore plus
de sens c'est l'attachement à cette
chaîne qui va vous faire tenir votre
résolution
entre nous c'est totalement contraire
aux principes de méditation mais tant
pis tant pis j'accepte les paradoxes
brennus
d'ailleurs tout ce que je viens de dire
marche aussi pour arrêter une mauvaise
habitude
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu c'est important pour moi de la
sortir du coup avant
les résolutions encore une fois
n'écoutait pas les gens qui vous disent
ouais les résolutions ça marche pas je
crois pas match à glace et je comprends
en fait parce que quand on n'a pas les
bonnes méthodes
quand on sait pas par où commencer et
c'est là évidemment c'est hyper dur en
fait de créer une habitude du screen
résolution voilà moi j'ai réussi cette
année je suis hyper content ça se trouve
les résolutions de l'année prochaine que
je me fixe et je vais pas y arriver j'en
sais rien et peut-être que ça donnera
lieu à une nouvelle vidéo pour pourvoir
quoi n'hésite pas à me dire dans les
commentaires
les résolutions que vous avez prévu
peut-être que ça va vous donner des
idées entre vous et comment vous vous
faites peut-être que parmi vous il y en
a aussi qui arrivent à se crée des
habitudes autrement donc ça ce qui
m'intéresse aussi donc il s'était pas le
mettre en commentaire
vous êtes 400000 maintenant sur cette
chaîne youtube merci beaucoup mais ça me
touche énormément
je suis un peu moins actif sur youtube
malheureusement à cause d'eux notamment
déménagement etc
donc c'est quelque chose qui prend vous
savez moi j'ai besoin d'avoir un espace
où je me sens un peu bien où je prenne
les caméras c'est pas vraiment le cas je
vais tout faire pour ce soit le cas
rapidement
du coup on n'hésite pas à me suivre sur
twitter et instagram c'est là où je suis
le plus actif par exemple sur instagram
gmi que j'avais rencontré hubert reeves
récemment avec mon ami tom aguilar pour
notre podcast
parce que vous saviez que j'avais un
podcast car il marche très bien on est
très contents donc merci beaucoup à ceux
qui suivent sur podcast
r j'en ai jamais parlé en vidéo et
marchera m donc je suis assez content je
vous souhaite de très bonnes fêtes à
tous que vous soyez seul ou en famille
vraiment je vous envoie le maximum donc
positive et je souhaite aussi une très
très bonne année la santé avant tout
l'amour et la réussite voilà j'aurais dû
l'homme et de la pisse chao savoir ce
que je suis sûr qu'il ya encore des gens
dans les contacts mieux ils nous
envoient de la piscine du pipi
ouais ouais c'est la havane laval salle
à vannes depuis six ans mon gars tu
l'avais là puisqu elle